So how do choose which
market segmentation to use?
You want to look for buyers that
are filling strong pin points, and
also have money, a sense of urgency and
a good fit with the features of your
current version of your product.
We can go with your
graphics segmentation and
choose our own city to start with.
This will allow us to map out
all the local competitors and
easily research potential
clients at the dog parks.
On the other hand we could focus
on behavioral segmentation and
target people with dogs
who vacations frequently.
Focus, focus, focus.
It will help you to
develop a clear messaging.
And will make it easier to decide
what product features to build next.
You can focus on building the best
product for this segment's needs.
Don't compromise on 80%
satisfaction of few segments.
Make one specific segment very,
very heavy with your product.
Let's ask Geoffrey Moore for
his advice on choosing the most
valuable market segment to begin with.